I thought that it was I loved it because
I I thought that it was like the most
truthful account of heartbreak and and
loss and grief
[Applause]
[Music]
Taylor gets candid and opens up to
Martin McDonough on varieties directors
on directors it was so exciting to kind
of go through it and to be able to be
you know in my 30s looking back because
I think there's a moment when you're 19
or 20 where your heart is so
so susceptible to tating just getting
broken getting shattered and and your
sense of self goes out the window so
quickly
as for lizzo it's about damn time she's
found the love of her life and she's
telling Howard Stern boyfriend Mike
Wright is it for her I am very much in
love and with Mike Mike we just recently
were like oh we together we this is
official because I'm very I'm very like
traditional about certain things like we
need to have the talk it needs to be
like discussed and she reveals that
truth hurts came from a really emotional
place
[Music]
I was going through you know some some
personal
the issues and I was sad and everything
that was happening to me Ricky Reed was
writing it down and he was like do you
realize you just wrote a song and I was
like no I'm crying right now
Myers making an appearance on his hit
series go day drinking okay this is my
first drink of the night from first to
last and this is my last some drink of
the night